hier soir M6 diffusé un nouveau numéro
de L'Amour est dans le pré on va
débriefer l'émission avec un invité ce
soir on va être avec Jean-Michel vous
rappelez de Jean-Michel ah oui bien sûr
il est bah il est là il est
là Jean-Michel de la saison 6 de
l'émission Jean-Michel je l'adore en
plus Jean-Michel clavau c'est un des mes
préférés il avait participé à la saison
6 en 2011 il avait deux prétendantes
Nathalie Alexandra et au moment de leur
annoncer son choix il avait fait
vraiment le bonhomme c'est un petit peu
le le le le Robert De Niro de l'amour
est dans le Prix
regardez bonsoir bonsoir vous être
rissance
merci donc ce qu'on va faire j'ai pris
une décision donc vous avez passé chacun
votre tour je vais commencer par toi
Alexandra hm hm donc tu vas monter dans
ta chambre s'il te plaît natthalie
d'accord et s'il te plaît quand
Alexandra va mon dans sa chambre je veux
pas que vous voyez pourquoi parce que
c'est comme ça
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel qui est avec
nous et merci d'être là Jean-Michel je
suis très heureux de te voir de rien
également et je voudrais dire j'embrasse
tous les agriculteurs qui sont voilà que
à chaque fois que j'ai reçu des
agriculteurs sur le plateau voilà j'ai
trouvé que c'était des gens formidables
et comme je disais voilà il y a des
métiers très importants parler hein des
professeurs voilà des hôpitaux et les
agriculteurs font partie des métiers les
plus importants en France et on les aime
nos agriculteurs il faut les protéger
parce qu'ils sont souvent dans la galère
et on fait pas assez pour eux et je le
redis encore ce soir parce qu'on parle
de l'amour et dans le prê je le rediris
d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'on le fait je
vous dis il faut aider les agriculteurs
parce que je trouve que le gouvernement
vous êtes pas assez voilà vraiment
pas facile merci d'être là Jean-Michel
alors vous aviez choisi Natalie à
l'époque et pour la convaincre de votre
amour vous aviez fait un un move de
drague plutôt
original je va te faire écter une
chanson oui tu vas l'écouter mais un
conseil s'il te plaît pleure pas parce
que j' obligé de
[Musique]
t'accpagner je l'entend je prends mais
j'ai plus envie d'y croire je les
apprends comme un enfant mais je ne veux
plus les
voir c'est
[Musique]
joli bravo Jean-Michel alors
Jean-Michel je veux pas que tu nous
dises où tu en est tu nous le diras
après parce que je veux en savoir plus
sur toi tu nous diras aprè parce que on
va faire déjà le débrief de l'épisode
d'hier tu regardes toujours l'M sur
laamour dans le prê ouais non non pas du
tout non ça fait depu chier non ça me
fait pas chier c'est que je trouve que
c'est plus comme avant ah ouais bah ça
tu vas nous en parler pourquoi qu'est-ce
qui qu'est-ce qui a changé ben je trouve
qu'il faut voir les grosses fermes il
faut voir que les agriculteurs gagnent
bien leur vie pu c'est pas vrai ouais
c'est ça donc voilà je trouve ça c'est
dommage ouais toi tu trouvais que
c'était mieux avant ou il montrait
vraiment voétait mieux avant il faisait
voir les petites fer voilà les
agriculteurs étaient en difficulté donc
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant ce que tu
dis là parce que tu dis que maintenant
il y a que des grosses fermes dans dans
la le problème c'est c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on veut faire des usines
ouais c'est ça
ouais donc je trouve ça dommage ouais tu
tu es pas content j'ai l'impression bah
on a pas le choix ouais mais bon alors
il y avait un couple hier c'est Charles
et Véronique dans l'épisode d'hier il
est parti la retrouver chez elle il a
l'air très content de la revoir mais lui
le romantisme c'est pas son truc
regardez et séparé de ces plus belles
claquettes chaussettes que notre véau à
cour vers l'élu de son
cœur
je suis très très très contente d'on se
revoir ah ou ça c'est la douche oui on
va se casser
Lau machine à la ça vibre
[Musique]
ouais
enfin arrête et ver qui cherche le
levier de vitesse non mais on peut pas
les tenir ces deux
là hier la dans le prê ah ouais c'est
vrai que alors malgré la bonne ambiance
et les po po de camion Charles a fait
une blague qui n'a pas vraiment plu à
ver qui est hyper jalouse et on a même
cru que c'était la fin de l'aventure
pour eux heureusement tout s bien
terminé regardez jolie serveuse et
Charles comme bon nombre de garçons a
les yeux qui traînent elle est bien
jolie oh ça y est oh ça y est oh
oh je suis resté bloqué là-dessus et
puis après B que ça plî ça plaît pas bah
c'est la preuve que que je tiens à toi
on serait pas
jalouse je vais pas te quitter comme ça
c'est pas parce que je parle comme ça
que j'ai parlé comme ça t'inquiète
[Musique]
pas je te laisserai
pas mais qu'est-ce qu' ai lui parce que
il a juste fait un petit compliment
elle est bien jolie c'est plus qu'un
compliment
quoi vous êtes avec votre femme vous
regarder une seruse elle est bien
jolie même temps là qu-ce penses toi je
pense la même chose que vous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
quoi
il il a dit je pense la même chose que
vous j'ai rien dit moi non non mais bon
après voilà après voilà c'est c'est bon
et toi toi tu en es où toi ah
aujourd'hui ça va je suis un homme
heureux ma vie va très bien j'étais
voilà j'ai eu j'ai eu des gros problèmes
dans les problèmes financiers tout ça
j'étais j'étais descendu au plus bas
donc je pouvais que remonter et
aujourd'hui j'ai bien remonté la p
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé bah j'ai voulu
me suicider parce que moi j'ai perdu ma
ferme et je brouillais du noir donc je
me renfermais et puis euh la suite de
après la MO dans le pressin après oui
parce que j'ai perdu ma ferme et donc ma
ferme voilà mes vaches c'était tout pour
moi donc tu fais quoi aujourd'hui jemich
aujourd'hui je le droit de cité je
travaille pour le groupe Vinc je suis
entretien les abords d'accord et puis je
suis heureux comme ça maintenant je j'ai
acheté une maison ça fait 3 ans ou là
oua donc le lundi je signé mon CDI et le
vendredi je signé le compromis pour
acheter ma maison
bien donc puis là du coup mois de mai
j'ai créé ma propre maison édition ouais
je sais j'ai vu tu tuas des livres un
hom he Liv voilà un homme heureux c'est
mon dernier livre les animaux ne montent
pas et ne jugent pas je suis
d'accord et je verse un Arou pour les
Chen guides et mon un homme heureux je
l'ai écrit avec mon ami Alexis Alexis
chartra on s'est rencontré dans une
dédicace et puis on a décidé de faire un
lit ensemble et tu en es où
sentimentalement aujourd'hui je suis
célibataire puis pour le moment je suis
bien comme ça ouais tu es tranquille de
va ça fait combien de temps que tu tu as
pas de de meuf ça fait à peu près 3 mois
3 mois ça
[Applaudissements]
il aé le
biscuiton il a trompé c'est vra il a
trompé son c'est bon parce que fait
mois t'a aidé quand même l'amour dans le
Pr je ser pas aujourd'hui mais là je je
te 100 € JeanMichel je suis tellement
cont pour toi merci c'est gentil et donc
là ça c'est fini pourquoi il y a 3 mois
on a décidé parce que cétait après voilà
n regarde tous les deux ouais d'cord
d'cord pas ouf quoi voilà tu rest
combien de temps avec je suis resté 3
semaines oh ça
va rig mais
raison RA pas une histoire
de avant chou je suis resté presque 2
ans avec
dis-moi toi tu
esment je suis comme tout le monde monde
qui tu étais avec une meuf pendant 2 ans
ouais presque 2 ans ouais et tu l'as
connu comment je l'ai connu euh je l'ai
connu sur les réseaux sur facebook donc
et alors vous êtes resté 2 an donc
cétait une bonne his et pourquoi c'est
fini parce que c'est pareil on accordé
un accord on a décidé par un accord un
accord mais tu signes des accords non
non parce qu'en fait moi j'ai acheté une
maison et j'avais acheté une maison à
avant et elle voulait pas déménager non
donc euh VO moi je voulais à ma propre
maison donc ou si pas déménager
oui Kell est-ce que les femmes que tu
Péchaud depuis l'émission que tu as fait
à l'époque c'est des femmes qui t'ont vu
et qui sont un petit peu fan de toi ou
ce sont des dames qui savent pas qui tu
es et les 3/4 c'est les femmes que qui
m'ont vu après les tr/ il a
combien ça veut dire que toi tu as fait
l'émission quelle année toi 2011 ça veut
dire que en 11 ans apparemment tu as
tuas tuas rou ta bossse bah je me plains
pas tuas tu as P combien de meufs depuis
de je sais pas je pr
pr rigol sans rigoler une
[Applaudissements]
vingtaine le gars il est rentré dans
l'amour et dans le cétait c'était
Monseigneur monseigur lu il est sorti
[Applaudissements]
che
unuc mais par parents non non depuis
depuis
l'émissionion e c'est beau oh là ça t'a
bien aidé l'émission comment bien aidé
l'émission ah oui oui moi l'émission je
regrette
pas
oua j'ai passé des bons moments tout ça
donc m'étonne oui après est-ce qu'il y a
une meuf qui a eu un coup de cœur et ça
c'est fini euh oui j'ai j'ai une fille F
oui que j'ai un coup de cœur que j'ai
toujours aujourd'hui c'est Nathalie
l'amétisste elle est toujours dans mon
cœur t toute ma vie dans mon cœur on est
où j'ai plus de nouvelle attention pas
de nouvelle bonne
nouvelle pas de nouvelle pendant très
longtemps très mauvaise nouvelle
va voir ce soir
peut-êtreie tu saiselle est déclaration
ah je sais pas faire une déclaration ça
peut passer non
non t juste une question si a toujours
la ch love love tou la chèvre love
love c'est un débutalie est-ce que tu as
toujours la chèvre love love question de
jeanm hier ce qui a été très commenté
sur les réseaux c'est l'attitude
d'Olivier l'éleveur de nouvelle aquitain
qui clairement semble n'avoir rien à
de sa prétendante
Corine elle a tellement elle ça l'a
tellement choqué qu'elle n'arrive même
plus à trouver les
mots
regard je mettre un je grosse
suite
le café il est fait si tu veux oui ou
attends je suis en train de passer un
coup de F je te l'ai pas servi pour que
tu les ches allô allô oui oui allô allô
je vais aller me changer après Olivier
parce que je vais avoiris habill comme
ça le temps et ohaise c'est au revoir
Corine bon retour merci et merci de ta
hospitalisation hospitalisation
hospitalité hospitalité merci et ben bon
retour 1 heure hier soir qu'est-ce que
tu en penses tuaimes pas ça tuaimes pas
l'attitude du gars ah si j'aime bien ah
ou après la façon de dire non mais bon
après bouge à fin tu t'enas les steaks
quoi non je m'as pas les steaks mais
bonux
dire ouais oui c'est pas beau il
s'intéresse pas du tout à elle il est en
train de téléphoner parce qu'il a une
CHF qui a été égorgée peut-être par un
loup c'est très important mais c'est
très important mais elle elle est là il
est complètement indifférent donc au
bout d'un moment elle dit je ne compte
pas je ne suis pas là je m'en vais voilà
il il a per surtout une femme adorable
la veille elle lui avait organisé la
veille elle lui avait organisé une
soirée au karaoké il a été odieux j'aime
pas le karaokeé il a fait aucun effort
elle elle voilà elle elle a pris elle a
quand même essayé de de le calmer d'être
sympa et le matin horrible mais c'est un
goujà fini al pas être sympa il est
bruit de décoffrage il est nature s est
vraiment comme
çam il va pas forcer sa
nature les amis làhaut on n pas chez vos
mèr on peut on peut pas quand même le
forcer à aimer cette
cette et après il y a des gens qui sont
qui ne se forcent pas à aimer il est
peut-être aussi timide et gêné et mal à
l'aise pour elle de lui dire bah écoute
tu ne m'intéresse pas donc parfois les
gens manquent un peu d'honnêteté mais
par gentillesse donc c'est c'est aussi
compliqué on pas sympa mais tu as pas dû
voir l'émission il c'est unou fini c'est
horrible tu pas de respect mais non mais
elle fait
tous mais oh c'est pas parce que tu es
un petit peu bien habillé que tu
dois c'est bon nous aussi on a des
habilles désolé tiens
oui mais je pense à un truc j'ai mis tes
célibes oui oh c'est
[Applaudissements]
V
m pour
semain j'ai une meu pour toi
bien sûr Daniel est
célibataire moi aussi mais bon quoi qui
toi aussi voilà pour un dîner toute
amitié avec
[Musique]
plaisir en langage agriculteur c'est
unato je vous le confirme je connais un
petit peu le langage agriculteur c'est
parato et je le dis ha effort non mais
Daniel ça aurait pu être ton style j bah
je sais pas mais on aurait pu creuser on
aurait pu creuser un pe faut apprendre à
se
connaître je te dire jeanm est-ce que tu
vas aller dîner avec Daniel oui avec
grand plaisir et tu penses que voilà tu
fais conna aprsamié pe se transform en
amour comme ça faut laisser les choses
autant et peut-être que bientôt il y
aura grand papa dans
grandmaman
on va pas se
mentir non mais c'est vrai on va pas se
mentir alors il y en a une autre qui
part et qui sait pas son choix c'est
Elodie la prétendante de Joris
l'agriculteur préfère Karine et on sent
qu'Elodie elle a pas du tout envie que
ça marche pour sa concurrence elle veut
leur mettre des bâton dans les roues
regardez effectivement j'ai un ressenti
que voilà vous devenez vous devenez de
plus en plus complice tu te dois vivre
ici sais entre le dire et le faire pece
qu'au début tu aurais du mal un peu à t'
habitué à la campagne ça te ferait rien
d'être aussi loin de tes parents moi
j'espère pour toi que Karine va
s'intégrer ou parce que je pense que le
changement le changement de vie là et
elle a pas le permis aussi hein tu vas
devoir la
voyager je suis très contente de vous
avoir rencontré tous les deux autant
l'un que l'autre pareil franchement je
vous apprécie beaucoup et franchement je
croise les doigts
pour on sent que c'est pas ouf
boules euh Jean toi tu es tu en tu es
sur un bail ou pas en ce moment un bail
de meuf ou pas du tout pas du tout pas
du tout là ça va très bien comme ça non
j'ai pas mal dédicace j'ai pas mal de
marché de Noël donc je suis pris avec
mes livres donc pour le moment ouais
pour l'instant après je peux ça me marie
rencontrer des gens voilà dans les
salons de livres dans les marchés de
Noël bah pour l'instant avant Noël tu
feras rien quoi je sais
Pasir pass avec les boules au pied du
sapin je te dis voilà je te demande moi
voilà alors hier céit un épisode
particulièrement émouvant parce que
c'était la fin de l'aventure pour pas
mal de prétendantes et de prétendants
qui nuront pas vu long feu l'aventure on
leur rend homage ce soir big up à tous
clold firm Elodie Corine
es sont pas
mort Cloti le suspense sera de courte
durée point de vue feeling sensation ben
c'est vrai que j'ai eu moins de moins
d'approche avec toi compris écoutez
profitez bien je vous fais des gros
bisous
bisous allez ça roule ouais nickel allez
bisous bisous prenez soin de vous
ciao j'ai beaucoup réfléchi et je t'aime
beaucoup franchement je mais j'ai pas je
ressens rien non mais c'est enfin pour
moi malheureusement l'aventure
s'arrête mais par contre si tu veux bien
qu'on reste en contact même moi je
t'aime
bien
e c'est dur hein de de faire son choix
céit dur dans l'aventure c'est un câble
ouais c'est vrai que c'est dur faut faut
bien choisir la bonne personne c'est pas
évident et alors tbetoi pour l'instant
on reste comme ça tu as pas envie de
statuo après si voilà si je tuhabites où
là en ce moment j je suis j'habite à
côté saintementouren enfin à côté de
tour à Tavant d'accord tu restes sur
Paname ce soir là ce soir je reste à
Paris bah dîner alors on va dîner avec
pasîn avec Daniel bah pourquoi pas tu D
avec qui ce soir je suis tout seul
oh je dire quand le destin frappe à
Tai il est où Jean Didier que je tire la
carte là
pourme je l'ai même pas vu partir cel
il son tar
c'estonuis on l'embrasse on
l'bre merci d'avoir été là est-ce que tu
as autre truc dernier truc à nous dire
sur l'amour est dans le Pr donc tu
kiffes plus non je regarde plus je vous
dire la vérité je regarde plus ça fait 4
ans que je regarde plus vraiment ah
ouais tu as fait un Roger quoi voilà
j'ai je trouve que c'est plus comme
avant mais c'est quoi qui à part à part
fut voir des grosses fermes il font voir
que les agriculteurs il gagnent de
l'argent donc les autres agriculteurs
ils disent quoi bah après moi je suis
ils sont comme moi il y en a certains
qui regardent il y qui regardent plus
dis ils disent comme toi souvent oui
donc bon écoute aujourd'hui tu es
heureux aujourd'hui je suis heureux donc
salarié là aujourd'hui je suis salarié
pu j'ai créé ma propre maison édition
donc ouais salarié tu as créé ta propre
maison d'édition les animaux de mone pas
il ne juge pas tuas un très beau livre
avec des B photos a un très beau
chevreuil en
couverture c'est beau c'est c'est un
loup ça oui c'est pas un loup c'est un
chien on dirait un
Lou compru
[Applaudissements]
franchement tu chipotes tu chipotes je
chipote pas pour moi c'est un loup et un
homme heureux Jean-Michel si tu racontes
quoi dans dans ça par tu as l'air pas
heureux de ouf là tu tu l'air heureux de
ouf en fait je raconte ma vie que j'ai
écrit avec Alexis ch ouais donc on l'
écrit ensemble et je raconte ma vie de
de ma naissance à aujourd'hui donc c'est
un très beau livre on Leit quand même
min même si tu regardes plus l'amour est
dans le prê a changer ta vie bah oui ah
oui c'est clair oui franchement je regr
pas puis Karine elle est vraiment
adorable donc je
l'adore et c'est toujours tu es toujours
un peu sur
Nathalie Nathalie c'est qui comment elle
s'appelle naalie la chvre love la ch
Natalie oui toujours sur elle non pu
aujourd'hui une autre Natalie que j'ai
connu une métis
Natalie dis
fait alle
frérot un lou en fait c'est un jour une
meuf c'est un loup le gars
c'est donc là c'est un autre bail encore
bon très bien on espère que ça va se
faire elle a quelqu'un ou pas ah j'ai
plus de nouvelle non plus
alors écoute en tout cas on te souhaite
beaucoup de bonheur mer beaucoupû tu
sais que tu vas bon dîner ce soir ce so
tu vasir tu vas ou non mais vraiment
est-ce c'est vous qui payez
le est- c'est pay
à tout de
suite